die große sportanlage in der wiener
maria theresien kaserne wird das neue
zentrum des heeres sports am montag
fällt dazu der startschuss
vor allem aus sicht des
eine wesentliche weiche gestellt das ist
ein riesengroßer schritt für uns und ein
jubeltag heute die vorteile sind dass
die gesamtstruktur des jahres
sportzentrums an einem platz feiern sind
und das bringt zweifellos viele vorteile
die daher im sport in zukunft gut
gebrauchen wird können dass das
sportliche leistungsniveau im bundesheer
aber auf dem richtigen weg ist davon ist
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
überzeugt mit uns nicht geben würde dann
würde auch die bilanz
oder anderen wettbewerb gänzlich anders
ausschaut zur erinnerung bei den letzten
olympischen sommer und winterspielen in
tokio und peking haben 110 herres
sportlerinnen und heeressportler 21
medaillen geholt und damit alle
erwartungen übertroffen wenn man diese
qualität weiter beibehalten will dann
muss man auch schauen dass die
rahmenbedingungen dementsprechend
vorhanden sind hier finden wir sie vor
nach 33 jahren kehrt des heeres
sportzentrum wieder in die maria
theresien kaserne zurück ob damit die
sportlichen erfolge noch mehr werden
wird sich zeigen die motivation ist
durch die übersiedlung ebenfalls
gestiegen
nicht nur mich sondern mein ganzes haus
es ist etwas worauf wir und meine
vorgänger auch schon jahre lang darauf
hingearbeitet haben wir schlagen